wir wollen einmal ins gespräch wolfgang
kubicki reinholen herr kubicki wir haben
es gerade gesagt ab oktober die
testpflicht für ungeimpfte die
kostenlosen schnelltest werden
abgeschafft ab dem 11 oktober was halten
sie davon wie reagieren sie darauf
jetzt zunächst einmal halte ich das für
unlogisch man kann nicht auf der einen
seite erklären wir wollen die
epidemische lage nationaler tragweite
verlängern die er die grundlage für
dieses ganze verordnungs maßnahmen sind
und gleichzeitig erklären wir machen die
tests kostenpflichtig in der sicheren
erkenntnis dass ein weniger menschen
sich testen lassen die frage muss doch
sein können wir nicht durch eine
vielzahl von gästen die möglichst
niederschwellig angeboten werden müssen
und kostenlos sind diejenigen
identifizieren die infektiös sind die
zum pandemie gesteht beitragen können
und sieben charaktere zu schicken werden
die kostenpflichtige werden weniger
menschen daran teilnehmen dann sieht man
möglicherweise ort instanzen war werden
jetzt feststellen wer dann
infektionsträger ist aber das nicht ist
nicht der sinn der pandemie bekämpfe ich
halte das für in sich selbst unlogisch
ist auch für rechtlich äußerst
zweifelhaft kubicki sie haben mehrfach
davor gewarnt sozusagen vor dieser
impfpflicht durch die hintertür wenn sie
jetzt sagen das ist rechtlich
zweifelhaft gehen sie davon aus dass es
wieder gerichte gibt die diese
entscheidung kippen könnten
ja selbstverständlich wenn der staat
anordnet dass ich will für die teilhabe
an dem normalen gesellschaftlichen leben
nicht testen lassen muss also eine
testpflicht auslobt dann darf er dafür
die kosten übernehmen es gibt an den
steigungen des projekts lüneburg von der
letzte woche diese bemerkenswert finde
wie überhaupt die rechtsprechung
niedersachsen die grundrechte verteidigt
wie kein anderes gesicht momentan die
festgestellt haben dass beispielsweise
das schließen von diskotheken und bars
ab einer inzidenz von 10 in
niedersachsen unzulässig ist weil die
institute selbst gar keine aussagekraft
mehr hat fürst der infektionsgeschehen
alle menschen über 60 sind weit gehen
die durch gf die inzidenz bei menschen
über 60 liegt bei ungefähr 5 das waren
ja die gruppen die wir schützen müssen
weil von dort schwerer verläufe und auch
krankheitsfälle und auch todesfälle
ausgehen und das gesundheitssystem von
da belastet wird die inzidenz von 100
bei 20 em spielt infektions rechtlich
kaum eine große rolle schauen wir nach
dänemark die an ähnlich wie
großbritannien alles geöffnet nachdem
klar war die über 50 sind geimpft und
der rest verläuft bei denen die davon
betroffen sind falls ihr ein
mittelschwerer gretel und das
weihnachtslied das öl das system nicht
herr kubicki paul ronzheimer hat gerade
gesagt sie kritisieren das ist
mittlerweile seit langem nur eine solche
impfpflicht durch die hintertür aber sie
regieren ja an mehreren
landesregierungen mit vor allen dingen
in nordrhein westfalen ebenso in
schleswig-holstein dass es irland
sozusagen hat sie keine lust oder keine
kraft das zu stoppen
ja also nun bin ich nicht dafür
verantwortlich dass der minister bürger
dieses landes in der wk entscheidend ist
dass die verordnung in den ländern
erarbeitet umgesetzt werden müssen die
fpk ist ja kein gesetzgebendes organ
auch ganze ordner gern darüber werden
wir reden müssen aber jedenfalls ist
klar das haben sowohl mit lasche für die
regierung in nordrhein-westfalen gesagt
cdu fdp und auch daniel günther für die
koalitionsregierung schierstein es wird
mit uns keine verschärfung der maßnahme
kein lockdown team alles weitere werden
wir sehen ich halte die wirkungsweise
der maßnahmen dieser regierung der bund
gehöre auch für begrenzten am 26
september sehen wir neu und dann werden
wir weiter sehen ich kann nur sicher
sagen seine partei wir werden nichts
mittler haben von dem wir davon
überzeugt dass es rechtlich
problematisch nur verfassungsrechtlich
nicht zulässig ist also die
differenzierung zwischen getesteten die
impfen und genesen dies hat so denn auch
getestete können dokumentieren dass von
ihnen keine gefahr ausgeht dann hat der
infektionsschutz anhin herr kubicki wir
haben vor dieser sendung metern stöhr
gesprochen einem der bekanntesten
virologen und er hat gesagt er füllt
sich langsam so ein bisschen im
paralleluniversum geht ihnen das genauso
das ging mir deshalb genauso weil ich
immer das gefühl habe das was die
kanzlerin will was das bundeskanzleramt
werde und einige minister diese
mittragen läuft auf eine logik
politik hinaus dabei wissen wir dass wir
das virus nie wieder los werden die
weltgesundheitsorganisation hat erklärt
dieses virus wird in dem ich das heißt
es bleibt uns dauerhaft erhalten werden
ist ähnlich wie bei der grippe dauerhaft
auch dagegen schützen müssen die
überlegung wir müssen ins tänzen so
niedrig wie möglich halten machen nur
einen sinn bei den älteren
persönlichkeiten also bei denen über 60
zu den ich auch gehöre sie machen
wirklich keinen sinn weil die kinder bei
jugendlichen und bei jungen erwachsenen
dort wie gesagt spielt sich das
geschehen auf vergleichsweise niedrigen
wo ab die haben keine große sorge vor
schweren verläufen von todesfällen das
können wir statistisch auch ihr letzten
18 monaten gut beobachten herr kubicki
sie sagen gerade wir werden das virus
nie wieder los die frage ist natürlich
wann kommt das bei der bundesregierung
an beziehungsweise wann ist da der punkt
erreicht wo man sagt okay wir können
jetzt einfach nicht mehr alles tun es
muss jetzt wieder normales leben
stattfinden was noch passieren dass das
gewährleistet ist ja zunächst mal müssen
sie begreifen dass sie sich auch in der
panini geht es scheint so zu sagen dass
es nur darauf ankommt einen guten zweck
zu formulieren und damit dass dann alles
erlaubt aber ich sage diese
bundesregierung sieht ja ende ihrem ende
entgegen nach den bundestagswahlen wird
eine neue regierung muss sie wird nicht
mehr von angela merkel geführt insofern
glaube ich schon dass wir dann wieder
etwas stärker auf dem boden der
wirklichkeit zurück kommen und uns
einrichten können mit dem was passiert
dass wir abwägen können sich
verschiedene güter die beeinträchtigt
sind allein wenn ich höre dass wir jetzt
diskutieren dürfen schulen aufgemacht
werden ja oder nein mein gott selbst
wenn sich dort kinder infizieren es ist
für sie in aller regel ungefährlich oder
sie hier sagen aber so beherrschbar und
so alle voraussetzungen war das
gesundheitssystem daten überlastet
werden und da fast mit ihrem einsatz
sein das habe ich dafür plädiere
eigentlich dem zu folgen was der kanzler
christa braun ende märz mal gesagt er
hat öffentlich erklärt hat wenn alle
menschen teams angebot bekommen haben
dann gibt es keine rechtliche grundlage
mehr die maßnahmen aufrecht zu erhalten
entscheiden sich die wie sich nicht
impfen lassen für möglicherweise ihre
eigene krankheit es gibt keine
veranlassung ungeimpfte vor sich selbst
zu schützen und ich sage mal ich habe
mich impfen lassen und ich plädieren
auch dafür dass ist alle machen weil ich
dann vor ungeimpften auch infekts musste
gar keine angst mehr muss das ist doch
die grundlagen unseres zusammenlebens
herr kubicki wenn man mal über die
entscheidung nachdenkt die jetzt schon
gefällt wurden nämlich unter anderem
dass dann das testen etwas kostet das
könnte dann ja für diejenigen die sich
eben nicht impfen lassen ziemlich teuer
werden selbst der kirchgang oder der
gang zum beichten würde dann am ende
etwas kosten ist das gerecht dass dann
kirchgänger am ende zahlen müssen ja
zunächst aber ist es absurd weil es ja
wie gesagt überhaupt nichts beiträgt zur
bekämpfung des panini geschehens es ist
vor allem auch eine soziale frage ich
könnte mir das locker leisten und viele
bundestag bangen wenn sie das locker
leisten die nicht die lebenslagen sind
aber viele menschen die ihm keine so
hohen einkünfte haben wie ich können
sich das nicht leisten die würden vom
gesellschaftlichen ausgeschlossen werden
abgesehen davon dass ich gespannt gegen
die der bürokratische aufwand gehandelt
werden soll denn für die kinder unter
zwölf jahren für die jugendlichen
zwischen 13 und 17 jahren soll es der
kostenfrei bei neben sich die für stange
oder für kranke die keine impfung
vertragen mit dieser bürokratische
aufwand das gehe über 20 millionen
menschen gestellt werden soll die zu
unterscheiden von denen die haben
kostenpflichtig werden sollen das gucke
ich mir alle obwohl gelassenheit an das
wird eine tobago geben und auch
unheimlich viele untereinander fragen
was machen wir mit denen die jetzt so
tobt empfindungen haben wenn ihr jetzt
zum arzt gehen und sich testen lassen
sollen sie das auch kostenpflichtig
werden dann geht keiner mehr zum arzt
aus lauter sorge auch um seine künftige
einkommenssituation also es ist in sich
selbst nicht konsequent zu ende gedacht
und ich hoffe nur dass in den ländern
noch das bewusstsein wächst dass man das
nicht eins zu eins umsetzt mit diesen
beschlüssen wird ja die
zweiklassengesellschaft ja zementiert
auf der einen seite die geimpften auf
der anderen seite die ungeimpften jetzt
haben sie selber gerade gesagt zu
welcher gruppe sie gehören das auch aus
überzeugung und trotzdem hat man eben
das gefühl im moment diejenigen die
millionen menschen das ist ja ein
massenphänomen bisher sich nicht impfen
zu lassen dass man die wie aussätzige
zunehmend behandelt wie gehen sie denn
ganz persönlich in ihrem privaten
persönlichen umfeld mit jenen um die
also ich möglicherweise aus überzeugung
nicht impfen lassen
nochmals sie haben das recht sich nicht
impfen zu lassen es gibt die
entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts je darauf
hinweisen dass ein menschlich auch für
eine krankheit entscheiden kann der muss
nicht gegen seinen willen gezwungen
werden gesund zu bleiben das haben wir
uns vielfältiger weise manche trinken zu
viel alkohol meinte erstens wie zucker
oder zu viel sei es also wir lassen ja
menschen die möglichkeit sich zu
entscheiden wie sie sich entwickeln
sollen ich habe wie gesagt getestet
überhaupt keine angst mehr und deshalb
unterschiedlich gar nicht mehr wer zu
bekommen ich frage auch niemanden bist
du gingst du nicht geimpft wie gesagt
weil ich mir die gewissheit verschafft
aber durch meine ihn so dass ich selbst
wenn ich an gesteckt werde was ihr
möglich ist es keinen schweren verlauf
geben wird und kein todesfall also die
angst ist mir ja genommen worden ich
will menschen zu treffen die nicht
gelöst sind ein comeback hin zum
abschluss eine frau was viele menschen
beschäftigt die frage warum reagiert die
kanzlerin so wie sie reagiert ganz zu
anfang das hören wir aus der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat sie
wieder davor gewarnt und gesagt die
zahlen könnten steigen wir müssen
deshalb jetzt reagieren und wenn wir mal
weiterschauen es gibt jetzt noch eine
bundestagssitzung dann kommt die wahl
aber dann sind im herbst
koalitionsverhandlungen das bedeutet mit
der situation jetzt also auch mit den
bestimmungen die da heute
durchgepeitscht werden sollen könnten
dann wieder lockt da uns beschlossen
werden wie problematisch ist dass
ich halte das für sehr problematisch wir
verlängern ja auf wunsch der großen
koalition also gegen die stimmen der
freien demokraten das kann ich schon
sagen die hygienische lage nach seiner
tragweite weil diese regierung ihre
arbeit nicht erledigt hat denn
vielfältige verordnungen die auch das
krankenhaus system betreffen die
finanzierung basierend auf den
infektionsschutzgesetz da wir keine neue
jetzt die grundlage haben müssen sie das
zwangsläufig verlängern weil von heute
auf morgen was die
krankenhausfinanzierung zusammenbrechen
würde das kann keiner wirklich wollen
aber in der tat glaube ich es wäre jetzt
an armin laschet er ist der
kanzlerkandidat der union weit deutlich
zu machen was er denn er ist derjenige
der dieses land künftig führen will der
darf sich nicht auf der nase herumtanzen
lassen von dieser bundeskanzlerin vor
der ich glaube dass sie ihre eigenen
angst blase gefangen ist und nicht mehr
die wirklichkeit wird nicht vor augen
wird in ihrer eigenen angst blase
gefangen das nimmer mit wolfgang kubicki
danke an den fdp bundestags vize
präsidenten hier bei bild.de reif
während der korona gipfel ein paar
hundert meter von ihr entfernt im
kanzleramt weiter in lohhof danke
wolfgang kubicki wir sind bild und wir
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier und
vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren